yo
un ejemplo para la reparación y la
memoria en bélgica con rap team el hijo
de un simpatizante nazi y simón
granovsky superviviente del holocausto
han forjado 70 años después una estrecha
amistad
el perdón es un gran tema
y es que puedo decir que he podido
perdonar porque no he sentido odio
estoy energía me espera en el odio es
una enfermedad de la que nunca me he
contagiado la ley
ambos habían publicado sus memorias y un
joven de 16 años de la unión de judíos
progresistas de bélgica facilitó el
contacto tiene el reniega de su pasado
mientras que granovsky agradece esta
amistad ejemplar que les ha valido el
doctorado 'honoris causa' en dos
universidades belgas
la iglesia católica avanza en la lucha
por la igualdad racial el papá francisco
nombró cardenal al arzobispo de
washington wilton gregory es el primer
afroamericano en obtener este
reconocimiento y un conocido crítico
contra el silencio de la iglesia frente
a los abusos sexuales de menores
wii psp go away ricura los obispos
siempre tendremos el más profundo pesar
por aquellos que fueron abusados y deben
vivir con ese dolor toda su vida
gregory alcanzó popularidad mediática en
junio cuando criticó que el presidente
trump levantase una biblia frente a una
iglesia después de que la policía usase
gases lacrimógenos contra los
manifestantes del movimiento las vidas
negras importan
una gran conciencia colectiva al mawla
perdió una pierna en la guerra de siria
en 2012 frustrando su sueño de ser
futbolista hoy ocho años después es un
experto en prótesis trabaja en alepo
donde trata de hacer sentir fuertes y
seguros de sí mismos a sus pacientes
dándoles la oportunidad de volver a
caminar de nuevo
nuevos horizontes para el fútbol egipcio
paisaje y dar la que fuera capitana de
la selección femenina de egipto se ha
convertido en la primera mujer en
entrenar a un equipo masculino
profesional del fútbol en egipto al
principio piensan que porque una mujer
los está entrenando entonces no hay que
tomárselo en serio incluso se burlan
pero luego se dan cuenta de que van a
aprender y desarrollar sus habilidades
no es por azar yo he estudiado y tengo
una gran experiencia
el ideal goldie de cuarta división se
encuentra en giza y ha puesto su
confianza en haidar que es también el
primer entrenador hombre o mujer en
obtener un certificado de mánager de la
premia el fútbol continúa siendo un
ambiente muy masculino en egipto sin
embargo haidar tratará de demostrar que
los tiempos han cambiado
motivos para celebrar en las islas
galápagos de ecuador las autoridades
anunciaron que el censo de población de
pingüinos y cormoranes no voladores han
alcanzado una cifra récord uno de los
principales motivos ha sido la ausencia
de turistas en la zona de anidación de
estas especies a causa de la pandemia
ambos animales forman parte de la lista
roja de especies en peligro de extinción
por lo que esta noticia supone un
respiro para la conservación de la
biodiversidad
[Música]